[Music]
[Applause]
no to be gay nbc sports golf channel
analyst joining us from augusta noda how
are you today i'm doing great i'm so
excited to be on your show i dressed up
for you how does that sound i like it i
like it shirt and tie i like that um
and dan we go back a long way you've got
to promise me one thing if i ever go
into a coma don't discuss it on the show
please
okay
do you do you have something of
importance that you could loan me
and then i could keep it and then if you
went into a coma then like i would just
hold on to it yeah it seems like a very
sticky situation but let's just not go
there okay i'd rather talk about my
buddy and and the masters and this is
the great week we're having here okay
the best piece of memorabilia you have
from tiger is what
um
you know i have you know each of the
flags that he won during the tiger slam
i have one signed each of one signed by
him all in the sort of the same pile i
like that i like that so pretty simple
but still um you know unique if you put
them all together
how much time did you spend with him
yesterday or last night
not a whole lot um you know with the
pandemic the most time that i'd spent
with him was during the pnc championship
uh
this past december i got a chance to
catch up during the practice round
um i had my son with me charlie was
there they're the exact same age and um
you know tiger knows my my kids and you
know he was there when they were very
young as i was for charlie so it was
just kind of a fun relaxed atmosphere
to talk about everything the accident
the rehab you know what the future holds
and uh certainly didn't think we'd be
sitting here talking about what's
transpired over the last
48 hours
when do you think tiger got it in his
mind that this was actually possible to
play in the masters
i think when he saw the quality of shots
that he was hitting at pnc
i mean i know he's riding in a cart and
you know it's a it's a fun family type
of event but you know he hit some high
quality shots he had a little pop in the
bat a little bit more than i thought was
going to be there as far as club head
speed
hit some wonderful approach shots with
his irons and so
it made me sort of
step up step back a little bit and be
like hmm you know if he could just
figure out how to walk
72 to 90 holes you know because a lot of
people say well 72 holes is determined
but you got to play practice rounds too
so
um you know that was the whole part of
the equation was a 90 hole type of is it
possible and
uh he you know told me shortly
thereafter that he's taking no days off
every single day there's some part of
his schedule that's dedicated to this
rehabilitative process with
the future being unknown but obviously a
pencil circle around the masters which
you know has made many players over the
decades do some pretty crazy things well
you've known him for such a long time
there are a lot of people in this in the
world of sports where you say well
that'll never happen or that could never
happen or that that guy could ever win
or that team can't win
you know we've learned not i've learned
not to say that whether it's tom brady
or don't go down the list of great
players of all time and here we are with
tiger
i had a friend who uh was at medalist
where tiger plays at practices he said
he can hit shots he can't walk
and i thought well and then he can't
play augusta
and then all of a sudden he gets to
augusta and he's hitting shots but he's
able to walk a little bit so what what
is that experience
like for him
you know you would think hitting shots
at augusta that's the hard part
it's the hard part is in between hitting
those shots at augusta for tiger
right and you know just to put things
into focus you know this is one of the
hilliest if not the hilliest course the
players will face all year you know the
only other one might might be the
plantation course at kapalua that starts
the year off at the tournament of
champions and so you know this is not an
easy walk you know i i thought that
there was a better chance that he would
show up at st andrews it's a very flat
golf course
it's not as long as augusta and so you
know that might have been a better fit
but like i said the masters kind of
makes players do do crazy things and
push their bodies to the limit and
tiger's
very comfortable with pushing his body
putting the time in doing the rehab and
you know he has access to all the
available
uh treatment uh modalities that that
exist in sport are all at his house
you know cold pools and saunas and uh
different types of hyperbaric uh
chambers and things that he can just you
know add to his whole recovery
uh regimen
uh which which i think has helped him
get to this point but at the end of the
day he's put himself through a lot of
discomfort to get here
i i've said this you know the last two
hours it felt like as i'm watching him
that he's already won
that that he set the goal of getting
here
and then he played well and he heard the
crowd he he saw the the fellow
competitors like that there was a sense
of
that's a victory
now his sights are set on another
victory
you know tiger as well as anybody can
you sense that during rehab my goal was
to play in the masters
as a victory
well i think today will be the telling
round where where whether or not he
feels like he can actually win
you can you can train for an event you
can train as much as you want for
a competitive game um
a cycling race around a golf but until
you actually go through it with all the
pressure the stress the adrenaline the
highs the lows uh you know they were out
there for a long time yesterday the
round took a long time uh and he said it
in his post-round comments he's like you
know i'm extremely exhausted and
i'm as tired as i thought i'd be i'm
sore
and now he's he had about 20 to 21 hours
to recover
um and today we'll see within the first
probably three or four holes whether or
not
um it's all still there which i think
will be some compelling television
nota begay nbc sports golf channel
analyst joining us from augusta
do you think tiger can win
i do
uh he's not in
a player that's going to show up to an
event and i know we've talked about you
know he coined the phrase second sucks
and he still believes that like he wants
to
come out and not sort of have people
celebrate him or him celebrate himself
for overcoming these physical hurdles
and injuries but
you know he shows up here in in as peak
condition as he can with his game as
much intact as possible
and he went out there and he beat
players that have played over the last
two years which was his last start have
played over 40 events
um some high caliber players justin
thomas colin morikawa
um you know players that have won majors
and and
you know are at the top of their game he
went out there and he outperformed them
which i think is extraordinary how many
contenders do you think we have to win
it all
right now um usually every year it's
about a dozen players that can really
contend and win here at augusta it's you
know you throw the first timers out 91
players in the field there's 20 first
timers you throw sort of the the players
that have aged out the couples the
longers the alata balls and then you
throw out the players that aren't
playing very well so at the end of the
day you know maximum you're looking at
15 to 20 but i usually try and circle
about 10 to 12 names
on that list
um and it's a list of usual suspects you
can't this is not an event you can come
from off the pace
very well uh you know winners have
proven that you need to be within five
shots after
after the first round and if you're not
you've pretty much eliminate eliminated
yourself from from winning
it feels like tiger's embracing the
media just a little bit more than he
used to nota
danny's embracing everything a little
more than he used to you know he's
really
approaching golf and life with a sense
of appreciation i think a near-death
experience would would hopefully do that
to most people he realizes that
if it wasn't him you know there was
probably a better than 50 percent chance
they would have amputated his leg after
the accident 14 months ago
and the fact that it was tiger woods
they spent 14 hours in surgery trying to
save the leg they saved it
um he was in such bad condition let's
not forget that they couldn't move him
for three months you know he this is a
guy that has the access and the means to
everything to medical and and and
transportation and private jets and
everything and they still could not move
him for three months um
and it precluded him from being able to
see his family and it just kind of
speaks to the seriousness of the injury
and the fact that he's here and in a
competitive frame and only four shots
back of the lead
i i'm sitting here telling you this
still dumbfounded by how how this all
happened
what was that call or text like when you
were told tiger had been in the accident
it was a it was a dark
dark time your mind starts racing and
then you start texting and calling your
own network to see if you could get any
information on you know did he survive
is he gonna survive what's what's the
outlook i mean
um
you really just start to
go through sort of the worst scenarios
in your head and um you know that was
the time where i i you know i thought
there was a good chance i was going to
lose one of my best friends in the world
and it was a scary point in the fact
that he came out of there you know with
with the leg and and was gonna you know
had
a good recovery on the horizon was
enough for me but
you know he he just has this burning
desire to compete and to get out there
and to push himself and i think that
came again a big part
simply because
he was so much better than everybody
else at his peak period that he had to
learn
how to self-motivate
and there's really no reason for him to
be back here in terms of he does not
need to prove anything to anyone the
2019 masters win was his drop the mic
moment yeah in terms of look i've won i
proved you i can come back and now i'm
out of here like he could have ridden
off into the sunset very easily but
that's just not how he's wired he felt
like he had some more good rounds in him
and he he himself told me he's like look
it's not going to be the same version of
tiger that you saw earlier in my career
it's going to be a different version and
i'm going to have to piece these rounds
together and you just saw him yesterday
i mean he was putting the ball in places
that when he was in trouble
seventh in the ninth hole he hit really
bad drives instead of trying to hit the
miraculous million dollar shot he laid
up to a spot where he could chip and he
pieced together two great pars there
which helped contribute to that overall
score so
um he he's not trying to pull the rabbit
out of the hat at least he didn't
yesterday
there will come a time where he will
have to do it but he's not going to do
that on a regular basis it's going to be
a different type of game he has to play
augusta the masters finally got around
to celebrating lee elder
um
now rest in peace uh he broke the color
barrier uh you're the first native
american to ever play at the masters is
that right that's correct yes
how is that celebrated i mean i
put in your world is that a big deal was
it celebrated
not not really um you know if i was a
basketball player coming from an
american indian community i think um
i would sort of have a bigger reach but
because golf's not all that prevalent in
our reservation communities um it's
because it's just by nature it's a very
tough sport to access it's uh
it's expensive um
it you know went
sort of unnoticed in a lot of areas but
there's a small group of people out
there that sort of appreciate sort of
the things i've done in terms of um
breaking down some barriers and setting
new standards about what's possible for
a young
native american kid out there that wants
to be in broadcasting that wants to be
in professional sports that wants to go
to a school like stanford and get an
economics degree and that that's really
all i'm trying to do i i don't
approach life with any expectation i
just try and do the best i can with what
i have and the opportunities that are
given me to try and get more of these
young native kids that are facing some
pretty dire circumstance in their own
life on a day-to-day basis a chance to
dream big and hopefully you know do what
they need to do
um to reach their dreams
always great to talk to you thanks for
joining us yeah it's great being on your
show dan
have a great weekend that's uh no to
begin golf channel analyst live from the
masters